well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight I am will Kane in for
Tucker
tonight unfortunately the world
continues to flirt with World War III
this morning according to the Associated
Press citing now a senior U.S
intelligence official
it said that Russian missiles did the
Associated Press quote crossed into NATO
member Poland killing two people
the Pentagon says that they are tracking
these reports though not confirming
anything right out of the gates here
though being very clear in saying that
the United States stands by Article 5
which is an attack on one attack on one
NATO country is an attack on all and
that is the concern here guys if these
were Russian missiles all we know right
now is that these were missiles or
rockets that landed in this farm that is
along the border of Poland and Ukraine
in Polish territories killing two and if
those were Russians and that is the
concern here that the Ukraine war could
extrapolate and become something bigger
whoa
extrapolate into something bigger now
that wouldn't be the first time that a
butterfly flapped its wings in Eastern
Europe
I give you the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand for World War One Buffs
and then a global war blew through
America so let's not extrapolate into a
nuclear conflict this time without
asking hard questions and asking for
sober leadership you heard in that
report The Mention Of Article Five
that's a self-defense provision in the
NATO Charter now if invoked it means
world war against Russia there's no
doubt about it and within minutes of
that apparent strike in Poland the
government of Estonia a NATO Ally made
it clear that world war might result
quote Estonia is ready to defend every
inch of NATO territory is America
now there are reports that instead of
Article 5 Poland will actually look to
invoke article 4. that would give them
the power to ask NATO to come together
for more support for Ukraine more money
perhaps air and anti-air power over
Ukraine and in fact
the White House today asked Congress for
another 37 billion dollars and of course
they'll get that for Ukraine in other
words whoever was responsible for that
missile strike in Poland well they're
about to get even richer defense
contractors
we we look we don't know what happened
yet in Poland we don't know where those
missiles came from we don't know what
was the intended target we don't know if
it was a mistake Russia denies launching
the attack the Pentagon hasn't confirmed
it even happened Ukraine's president
zielinski of course has blamed Russia
but we should know the answers to these
questions before we zombie walk into war
and these questions can't just be
brushed away with Putin apologist or
conspiracy theorist the same way that
was done with covet Origins vaccine
efficacy lockdown efficacy Max mask
efficacy or asking for details and facts
around the attack of Paul Pelosi more on
that in a moment
sadly though it's clear that our
leadership in Washington is in no shape
to handle any of this Joe Biden had to
skip dinner with the world leaders at
the G20 Summit last night in Bali
retreating back to his hotel room for
undisclosed reasons
he was just on television before we
broadcast looking quite confused in
front of Television cameras tonight it's
probably all better because if he were
awake or Lucid he might verbally stumble
us into Hiroshima words are power
speaking of the power of words like
famous basketball dad Lavar ball
speaking it into existence the head of
the DHS suggested our border is secure I
guess attempting to speak that
falsehood into existence as fentanyl
flows across and kills thousands of
Americans every month
I've heard you in the Judiciary
commission committee recently in the
summer testified that the border is
secure
secretary my orcas do you continue to
maintain that the border is secure
yes and we are working day in and day
out to enhance its security Alejandro
mayorcas undefeated never lost
in reality more than 230 000 people
cross the border last month compared to
just sixty thousand in October of 2019.
now this is what's actually happening at
the border courtesy of Fox's bill
malusion take a look at this video we
shot early this morning this is drone
video thermal drone video showing a
single massive group of several hundred
migrants Crossing illegally into the
Normandy Texas area Normandy is a tiny
little town on the Northern outskirts of
Eagle Pass and as you look at this
you'll see just a single file line of
migrants waiting across the Rio Grande
and entering Texas there's no resistance
on either side of the Border whatsoever
and once these migrants get to the U.S
side they simply crawl under a fence
that was put up by the state of Texas
and they walk into an area where they
wait to be processed by border patrol
and they're just a couple hours after
that thermal video across town in Eagle
Pass we had another group of migrants
Crossing illegally into the Eagle Pass
area this at a private pecan Orchard a
couple hundred single adults crossed in
this area with a border patrol Source
telling Fox News here in this Del Rio
sector just since October 1st there have
already been nearly 50 000 illegal
Crossings totally unimpeded how should
Republicans respond to a crisis like
this when the federal government as led
by the executive Joe Biden refuses to
act
well today it appears one Republican
actually did something about it
or did he Texas governor Greg Abbott
seemed to declare an invasion is in
progress at the southern border now
under the Constitution of the United
States and the constitution of Texas
that move would authorize Texas to
independently Crush The Surge of illegal
immigrants without needing any approval
from the federal government
specifically Greg Abbott's decision to
invoke The Invasion Clause would allow
Texas to deploy the National Guard and
Texas DPS to remove illegal immigrants
but in his press release today Texas
governor Greg Abbott said he would
remove illegal immigrants to the Border
wait
to the Border Ken cuccinelli he's the
former Attorney General of Virginia and
a big leader in this push for States to
declare an invasion points out to the
border is not deportation it wouldn't
stem the tide of illegal immigrants and
it doesn't invoke the full
constitutional power of declaring an
invasion so is it just a press release
another example of words or is this
potentially leadership
Republicans now have the house at any
moment tonight it could be called that
the Republicans now have the majority in
the house and then the question becomes
might they be able to lead in actually
solving the Border crisis or maybe
returning our elections to pre-pandemic
election laws or maybe even being that
sorely lacking sober leadership we need
before we extrapolate ourselves into
World War III
for too long now we've been gaslit we've
been shouted down we have been censored
our questions have been called
conspiracies while the English language
is tortured to the point where you can
no longer explain what is a woman or why
we're going to war we need leaders
honest leaders of any party at any level
of government to answer to act and to
remember that they work for us subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight